[Musik]
moskau heute hat das russische parlament
die wünsche wladimir putins erfüllt es
ratifiziert die unabhängigkeit der
ostukrainischen gebiet einen sogenannten
freundschaftsvertrag dafür
399 stimmen
dagegen 0 enthaltung 0
der kreml bericht offen das völkerrecht
der westen reagiert beschließt neue
sanktionen
und der deutsche bundeskanzler stoppt
nord stream 2 mit einer anweisung an die
bundesnetzagentur
es klingt zwar technisch ist aber der
nötige verwaltungsrechtliche ship damit
jetzt keine zertifizierung der pipeline
erfolgen kann und ohne diese
zertifizierung kann nur zwei ja nicht in
betrieb gehen russlands außenminister
sergei lavrov gibt sich unbeeindruckt
und bereits mit allen möglichen
sanktionen oder wie sie jetzt sagen mit
der mutter aller sanktionen nun wir sind
daran gewöhnt
russland hat sanktionen also längst
eingepreist war deutschland in der
vergangenheit zu zögerlich ich bleibe
weiterhin der auffassung dass es richtig
ist auf dialog zu setzen um eine
friedliche lösung herbeizuführen aber
zur dialogfähigkeit gehört eben auch die
wehrhaftigkeit und wir stehen jetzt an
der seite der ukraine unter anderen
staaten östlich der ist des östlichen
europas und wir haben uns jetzt in einem
ersten schritt zu weit reichenden
sanktionen entschlossen dabei ist
russlands aggressives auftreten
gegenüber seinen nachbarn seit langem
bekannt als 1991 die udssr verschwindet
entstehen auf dem boden der ehemaligen
sowjetunion neue start der kreml
betrachtet sie als zonen russische
einflussnahme ein beispiel aus dem jahr
2007 die sogenannte präsidenten
sprechstunde bürger dürfen putin fragen
stellen wie selbstverständlich wird nach
riga lettland geschaltet als gehöre der
baltische staat zum russischen imperiums
zu wort kommen vertreter der
russischsprachigen minderheit sie werde
angeblich unterdrückt
dabei bricht russland völkerrecht im
august 2008 dringen russische truppen in
georgien ein und besiegeln die
abspaltung zweier provinzen
der damalige russische präsident dimitri
medwedew klingt so ähnlich viel putin
heute
[Musik]
ich habe zwei dekrete unterschrieb mit
denen die russische föderation die
unabhängigkeit südossetiens und
abchasiens anerkannt
der westen verurteilt das russische
vorgehen auch deutschland
dieses widerspricht nach meiner und ich
glaube unsere auffassung dem prinzip der
territorialen integrität einem
grundlegenden prinzip des
internationalen völkerrechts und ist
deshalb absolut nicht akzeptabel es
bleibt bei worden und so werden
abchasien und südossetien auf dauer von
russland kontrolliert so schafft der
kreml einen eingefrorenen konflikt auch
anderswo in transnistrien moldawien
da karabach aserbaidschan auf der krim
und im donbass in der ukraine putin habe
klare ziele nun mit den eingefrorenen
konflikten hatte die eskalation dominanz
das heißt er kann sie jederzeit herauf
oder herunter drehen wir an einer skala
zweiter sichert er sich russischen
einfluss in diesen staaten und
ermöglicht diesen staaten keine
entwicklung in richtung
rechtsstaatlichkeit in richtung
regelbasierte internationale ordnung
in moldawien das auch nach westen strebt
hatte russland seit 30 jahren den
landesteil transnistrien besetzt und
zementiert die spaltung mit sogenannten
friedens drücken auch hier würde die
russischsprachige bevölkerung angeblich
bedroht
mit dieser behauptung verteidigt der
russische präsident 2014 auch den
völkerrechtswidrigen einmarsch auf die
krim acht jahre später ist putins
begründung die gleiche
jetzt wird der eindruck erweckt als
ginge die aggression von der ukraine aus
das ist natürlich gelogen es gibt nur
einen der verantwortlich ist für die
aggression und das ist präsident putin
selbst ob der von den heute
beschlossenen sanktionen war eindruck
ist fraglich die neue härte des westens
kommt spät vielleicht zu spät